-Complete
this search question --
Can you milk a "blank"?
-Oh.
-Again, family show.
Can you milk a "blank"?
Type it in,
whatever you think it is.
Tell me when
you are locked in.
-Okay.
-Locked and loaded.
-I'm locked and loaded.
-Press the red button.
-Alright.
Press the red button.
Miley, what did you write?
-Kitten.
[ Laughter ]
-And, K.J., what did you write?
-Goat.
Kitten and goat.
Let's see it!
[ Ding! ]
Cat, oh!
Team Cyrus the Nashville team
over here!
K.J., take a seat!
-Everyone knows
you can milk a goat.
Come on, man. Can you milk it --
That's the question.
-It's a little convenient
that the house keeps winning.
-No. Come on.
Jimmy and Lili,
you are up first.
Come on over.
Come on down.
[ Cheers ]
Here's how the game works.
I will read you the start of
an Internet search question,
and then you will fill
in the blank.
We have four of...
-Use your TV voice.
-...the most popular answers
on the board,
and you'll both type
as fast as you can.
We'll see if any of them match
the top four answers.
-Alright.
-Here's our first search.
Here's our first search.
Round one, Jimmy and Lili --
Should I pierce my "blank"?
[ Laughter ]
Is everybody locked in?
-Did I lock it in?
-Lock it in.
-Yeah.
-It's a family show.
Alright, Jimmy,
what did you write?
This is a Website I tried
to start and it didn't take off.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Tumblr type of thing.
This is called Nipplr.
And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
-Nipplr?
-Well, I meant to type nipple,
but I typed "nipplr."
-Nipplr.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a weather app.
-See if it's nippy out.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Sure, sure, sure.
-It's a weather app.
-You got to keep abreast
of the weather.
-Alright, Lili --
-Thank you.
-What did you type?
-I mean, I am strategic.
So, you know, I did with
what I thought would be
the right answer.
[ Laughter ]
So I --
-Oh, my God.
The sarcasm is insane.
Wow.
-I did nose.
-Nose.
Nose and nipplr, let's see them.
Whoa!
Got nipples and nose!
You got it!
♪♪
Alrighty.
-You got it.
-See?
-Rigged.
-Nipplr, man.
-Nipplr.
-Free the nipplr.
Free the nipplr.
Miley, how are you, my love?
-I'm great, how are you?
Once again, most popular word
to complete the search --
Should I pierce my "blank"?
-You're asking me?
-Yes.
-Remember --
-This is bad.
This is a family show.
-Alright, so my first one
is out the window.
-Right.
-What other things?
-So is your second and third.
-Alright, I have to go to, like,
my fifth answer.
-Yes.
-But do I say it out loud?
-[ Laughing ] Yes.
-Okay, it's --
-Yeah, say it to yourself.
-I'll say tongue.
-Tongue.
Should I pierce my tongue?
-That's good.
-Let's see tongue.
[ Buzzer ]
-Boom!
-That's a fail.
-I bet my real one
would have been good.
-I bet it would have been.
-Yeah.
You can whisper it
to me later.
Noah, how are you?
-Good, how are you?
-What is the answer?
Should I pierce my what?
-Should I pierce my ears?
-Ears!
-Yes, of course!
-Let's see ears.
Ears.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Number two answer.
Tish, darling.
-Keep it classy, Mom.
-Up there at number four.
-I'm going to keep it classy.
-Keep it classy.
What you got?
-My lip?
-Should I pierce my lip?
Let's see lip.
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Shouting indistinctly ]
-That is a fail.
Over to "Riverdale" to steal.
K.J.?
You guys got an answer?
-There's only so many things
you can pierce...
-That's true.
-...on the human body.
-Well, you maybe.
[ Laughter ]
-Zing!
You guys can confer,
confabulate.
-Can we call family members?
[ Talking over each other ]
-What is it?
-Belly button.
Let's see belly button.
If they get belly button --
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers ]
"Riverdale" won!
Wow.
-What are we talking about?
That was a barn-burner!
Time for round two.
K.J., Miley, you're up.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Complete this search question --
Can you milk a "blank"?
Again, family show.
Type it in,
whatever you think it is.
Tell me when
you are locked in.
-Okay.
-Locked and loaded.
-I'm locked and loaded.
-Press the red button.
-Alright.
Press the red button.
Miley, what did you write?
-Kitten.
[ Laughter ]
-And, K.J., what did you write?
-Goat.
Kitten and goat.
Let's see it!
[ Ding! ]
Cat, oh!
Team Cyrus the Nashville team
over here!
K.J., take a seat!
-Everyone knows
you can milk a goat.
Come on, man. Can you milk it --
That's the question.
-It's a little convenient
that the house keeps winning.
-No. Come on.
-We have no idea.
-I'm just kind of saying.
-Can you milk a cat?
I mean, who would know --
that's great.
[ Talking over each other ]
-Alright, Noah, to you.
-I don't know!
-Just think of one.
Think of one.
-A dog?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no no.
-I bet it's on there.
I bet it's on there.
-I bet it is.
-Let's see dog.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good job.
-What world do we live in?
Yikes. What is going on?
-We are from the South.
This isn't fair.
-This is weird.
-We're all Southern.
-Alright.
-We milk everything there.
-Right. You milk everything
in the South.
-Can you milk a --
-I mean,
I'm just gonna go with cow.
-Yes, thank you.
-Cow.
Let's see cow.
-Thank you.
[ Buzzer ]
-What?
-These are people...
-...asking the Internet.
-I know.
-They are asking the Internet,
can you milk this thing?
What is a thing that people
might think you can milk?
-Okay.
-People.
-Ew.
-No, it's my turn.
-Okay, sorry.
-It's Brandi's turn.
-I'm gonna go with llama.
-Llama.
-Llama!
-That's interesting.
-Okay.
-Now, if you don't get this one,
it's "Riverdale's" to steal.
-Can you --
let's see llama!
[ Buzzer ]
Ooh!
That's the second fail.
"Riverdale."
-Cole, what are you thinking?
-What do you guys got?
-It's our turn now.
-Yeah.
-It's team "Riverdale."
-What are we thinking?
What are we thinking?
-Or, or or --
-Huddle, huddle.
-What are we thinking?
[ Talking over each other ]
-Alright. You have it?
Your answer?
-You guys seem very confident.
-Take it away.
-We are.
-Cole, go for it.
-Pig.
-Pig! Let's see pig!
-Not bad.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Shouting ]
-No pig! Let's see
what the answers were.
[ Ding! ]
Horse!
-I told you.
[ Ding! ]
-And man.
[ Cheers ]
-Hey, now -- stop it.
Stop it. Stop it!
-Jiminy Christmas.
Let's get to the final round
and get this over.
-Alright.
The final round, Noah and Cole,
you are up.
-Noah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're going down.
You're going down.
-Okay, this is the final round.
This is for the game.
-Complete
this Internet search.
-No!
[ Laughter ]
-He didn't ask you yet.
-No, not yet.
-And then delete your history.
-Why are people
afraid of "blank"?
Tell me when you're locked in.
-Wait, what?
-I did it.
-Did you do it?
-Yeah?
-Alright, what did you write,
Noah?
-I wrote dogs.
-Why are people
afraid of dogs?
-Cole, what did you write?
-I wrote me.
-Why are people
afraid of me?
-People afraid of you?
No one is afraid of you.
-Alright, watch.
-Oh, really?
-Let's see. Let's see.
Me and dogs.
[ Buzzer ]
-No one is afraid
of either one.
-Jimmy.
-Well, that's comforting to me
at least.
-Why are people afraid
of the dark?
-Ooh, the dark.
-That's mine.
-Let's see dark.
-Are you speaking
from experience?
[ Ding! ]
-The dark!
Alright, team Cyrus
is going over there.
-Here we go.
Here we go.
-Ready to go back over there?
[ Applause ]
-Another one?
-Miley, it's up to you.
Why are people afraid of...
-Clowns?
-Ooh.
-Yes, of course.
-That's a good one.
-"It"!
-Very topical.
Very topical.
Let's see clowns.
[ Ding! ]
-That's number one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, Noah, round two?
-Again?
-Again.
-Oh. Okay.
-Things you are afraid of.
What are people afraid of?
-Oh, heights.
-Oh, that's a good one.
-Heights.
Let's see heights!
[ Buzzer ]
-First fail.
Tish, what do you think?
-Oh, I know. I know.
I know.
-One more fail.
-Why are people afraid of...?
-Ghosts.
-Yes!
-That was a good one.
-Let's see ghosts.
[ Buzzer ]
-Fail.
-Oh!
Over to "Riverdale" to steal.
They can win this entire game.
-If they don't win this,
we win the whole thing.
-No, if they win this,
they win the whole thing.
-That's right.
But if they lose this, we win.
-Then you win the whole thing.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-They get one guess.
You guys get one guess
to win this entire game.
-I know.
-Insects, insects.
-I know, I know.
-This is it,
for the win or the lose.
-Spiders.
-That's a very good answer.
Spiders, let's see spiders.
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a winner.
-My thanks to the Cyrus family,
my team.
The cast of "Riverdale."
-First up, Jimmy and Finn.
Get on up here.
-Here we go.
-Now...here's how
the game works.
I'll read the start
of an Internet search query...
-Okay, yeah.
-...and you will
fill in the blank.
We have the top three most
popular answers on the board.
You'll both type in answers
as fast as you can.
And then we'll see if they match
any of the top three.
-Okay. Is this from a poll --
a nationwide poll?
-Sure. Why not?
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, nationwide.
Here's the first --
Here's the first search.
Alright.
This is the question.
-My hands are as fast
as Bill Gates.
-There you go.
-Oh, mine's --
-I don't know if he types fast.
I just know he knows computers.
-Yeah, he does know computers.
-You're Mavis Beacon.
Okay, now, "Why did the '80s
have the worst blank?"
"Why did the '80s
What are the top three results?
-Really?
-Everybody's ready?
Okay.
-Wow.
-You're on my team.
That's good.
-Alright, Jimmy,
what did you write?
-But you're on his team.
-I'm sorry.
-Alright, are we locked in?
-You're locked in.
Is everybody locked in?
Alright, Jimmy,
what did you write?
-I wrote hair.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
Finn, what did you write?
-I wrote clothes.
-Whoa.
Let's see the answers
on the board.
-Oh!
-Wowee!
Okay.
-We scored the same amount
of points.
I don't know what --
-Okay.
Ready? Yep?
-No, no, no, no, no.
-Yep.
-Okay, okay.
-Oh, hey, I'm on the team.
-What?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, okay.
-Okay.
-Yeah, potentially.
Okay.
-"Why did the '80s
have the worst..."
-Music.
-Do we see music?
-Whoa!
-Yeah!
Wowee.
Oh, my gosh.
-I disagree.
-The music from the '80s...
-I'm playing the game.
I'm playing the game.
We disagree, but we are playing.
-I disagree with my own answer,
as well.
-Right.
You're just playing the game.
-Don't be salty.
-Wow.
-Is that an English thing?
-Don't be salty?
-Salty?
-No, just don't be.
-Wow.
-Don't be salty.
-Alright, Mr. Peanut.
Round two!
Millie, Caleb, you're up.
-Alright, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, wow.
-Wow!
-Cold-blooded.
-It's alright.
-I love you, but no.
-Nah, nah.
I don't like you, so it's fine.
-This is the game.
Here's the phrase.
"Will I regret eating
this whole blank?"
-I'm done.
-Oh, God.
-Okay, everybody's typing.
Everyone's typing.
-Do I press enter?
-Yep.
There you go. Ready?
Caleb, just type it in.
You're in.
-Yeah, it's so your credit.
-Wait.
-Yeah, yeah, Caleb.
-That's it.
-Can you possibly do that?
-Alright, ready?
-Yes, you can.
-Press return.
-Ready. Yeah.
-Everybody locked in?
-Yeah.
-Locked in.
-Millie, what did you write?
-Cake.
-Pizza pie.
Let's see the board.
-What?
-Oh!
Number-one answer.
Oh, my -- Oh, snap.
Oh, snap.
Oh, my God.
The mocking dance.
-We had that guy on our team.
What are you going to do, Jimmy?
-Alright, Gaten,
what are you going to say?
-Yeah, that guy.
-What do you think?
-That's the thing.
I can't tell.
I couldn't tell you.
-You got it. You got it.
"Will I regret eating
this whole..."
-Pint of ice cream.
Let's see it.
[ Cheering ]
Okay. One more, Tariq,
for the win.
-Ohh!
-To tie up the game.
"Will I regret eating
this whole..."
-Turkey?
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
Oh!
-Hey, hey.
-Wow.
Wow.
-That's a lot, though.
-That is a lot.
You're going to eat
a whole turkey.
That is a lot.
Alrighty.
-I'll give you $1,000
if turkey's up there.
-Let us see turkey.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
Now, over to you guys to steal.
Noah, what are you going to say?
It's up to you.
-Try it.
Just try it.
-I think it's going to be --
I think it's gonna be --
I -- What?
-Okay, I'm ready.
-Ready? What is it?
-Hey, hey!
-No, no, no, it was his idea.
-Alright.
Bag of chips.
-What?
-Will I regret eating
this whole bag of chips?
[ Cheering ]
Oh!
-But we got two, though.
But we got two, though.
-Okay, wow!
Bag o' chips.
-♪ Hello from the Upside Down ♪
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Alright.
-Did you guys write a song
before coming here?
-Here's what's great about you.
Here.
-Don't worry about it.
-I lost my name tag.
-What's great about me?
-Hey, here's
what's great about you.
Sorry.
Alright, sorry.
-Alright, it's time
for the final round.
-Thank you.
-This is for a billion points.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Noah and Gaten, you're up.
You're up.
-Alright, Gaten, you're up.
-Come on, man.
-This is for the game.
-Do not let Noah win.
-Do not let Noah win?
-Yeah.
-This is for the game.
Ready?
-Don't type your name.
Don't type your name.
-I'm practicing.
-"Should I get a new blank?"
-Oh.
-Oh, oh.
-What is it?
-No, just --
-Car.
-Right, ready?
Type it in.
-No!
-This is for 1 billion points.
-Car.
-[ Screams ]
-Oh, no.
-Boyfr--
-Okay.
-No, Noah, Noah.
-No, don't put it.
-No, no, only put one.
You only get one.
-Keep going.
-Enter, enter!
-Yeah, click enter.
-No, don't.
You're clicking erase.
-Oh, my God.
-Alright, just hang out.
-Apparently he wrote, "ohone,"
but phone.
We're gonna take phone.
Ohone. You got it.
-That can't count.
-That counts. Ohone counts.
-Ohone can't count.
-It's the spirit of the law.
What did you write?
-I wrote car.
I wrote car.
-Alright.
Car and phone.
[ Drumroll ]
Let's see them.
-Oh!
[ Cheering, shouting ]
-Oh, my God.
-My thanks to the cast
of "Stranger Things."
Check out "Stranger Things 3."